in a city which often prepares for
coming storms Miami is cranking up
security around the federal courthouse
has been increasing throughout the day
all agencies getting ready for the
historic first court appearance of a
former U.S president on federal charges
we're taking this uh this event
extremely serious we know that there is
a potential of things uh taking a turn
for the worst but that's not the Miami
way Donald Trump landed in Florida in
the late afternoon met by a small group
of supporters and protesters
back to the White House is going to be
even better president he's staying at
his Doral Golf Resort a 30-minute ride
from the court where he'll surrender to
the authorities on Tuesday once he
arrives at the court he will be
officially photographed and
fingerprinted it's a federal court there
will be no pictures of him before the
judge he'll then hear details of the 37
charges they include violations of the
Espionage Act obstruction of justice
making false statements and conspiracy
in a series of social media posts Trump
again claimed the prosecution was
political a point he made at rallies
over the weekend and I never thought
such a thing could happen to America
as far as the joke of an indictment it's
a horrible thing it's a horrible thing
for this country
I mean the only good thing about it is
it's driven my poll numbers way up can
you believe this well
Miami's Republican mayor refused to get
involved in the politics just urging
protesters to be peaceful I'm not here
to talk about politics I'm here in my
role as mayor of the city of Miami
projecting confidence to our residents
and to the residents of the country that
we're going to be ready for tomorrow the
courts in Miami is known for pushing its
cases through quickly a rocket docket
court is what they call it so while
Trump's team will argue that the
prosecutions are malicious and should be
dismissed there's every possibility the
former president could be on trial here
within six months Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Miami